foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored print
Supremacy Harry turns the Global
Spotlight again on himself with a staged
appearance at his latest privacy battle
against the British press to someone who
sells their own privacy to the highest
bidder and that of all his friends and
family wave their right to privacy we'll
debate that
Horror in Nashville America as the
shooter kills six people including three
children and yet another school shooting
can we at least agree that images like
this Christmas card from a local
Congressman probably don't help curb
America's gun violence epidemic
and as a string of failing MPS are
caught flogging their services to
thousands of pounds in an oven covered
steam could the answer be to pay
politicians a lot more money Constantine
kiss enjoys been live to argue that
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening Fernando welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored for a man who
reveres his privacy Prince Harry
certainly has a knack for making himself
the center of global attention
this is a show for Fearless debate so
let's have a Fearless debate about
Prince privacy Harry is seemingly
addicted
to invading his privacy invading the
privacy of his friends and families and
appearing in public places and making
sure that everyone talks about them he's
currently at the high court in London
he's flown 5 000 miles which is a good
thing to do if you're an Eco Warrior of
course watching your carbon footprint to
attend a case which involves the owners
of a Daily Mail newspaper accusing him
of breaching his privacy he's one of
many celebrities that are down there
number stage of a court case is all
about procedure there are no Witnesses
no evidence no box of this material the
hearings take place today and yesterday
and could have passed without anyone
really noticing but Harry wanted
everyone to see him uh he wanted to make
the front page news and he arrived uh
turning up with a big grin on his face
and leaving with a big grin on his face
looking like he's rather enjoying it all
um it's probably not the best look for
someone who's wanting us to believe that
he's in trauma because of the invasion
into his privacy which came just before
his own grotesque invasion of other
people's privacy
um so it's all a bit complicated isn't
it and he didn't slip in quietly through
the side entrance like some of the
others involved in this case he chose to
parade past the TV cameras barging past
some Paparazzi and marched through the
front Gates using the media that he
loves to invade his privacy
you see the problem here and he's loving
it look at him grinning away what a
laugh
nothing better than the cost of living
crisis and watching multi-millionaires
rocking up in court wanting money for
invasions of privacy just after they've
invaded their own so Harry
me to be rather confused about his
treatment by the media it's almost like
he wants to keep his privacy so he can
invade it when he's invading everybody
else's even our fair-minded peers on
neighboring networks appeared woken up
and sniffed the hypocritical coffee
he has been taking lots of notes again
today there's no need for him to be here
because all of the evidence that's being
presented on behalf of the claimants is
written and so it really is the fact
that he's appeared today was about sort
of being seen publicly
of course well Harry's hatred of the
media was laid Baron 6000 media bashing
for Netflix which ironically is the same
Media Company it just happens to paid
him a hundred million dollars and of
course is also airing the crown which
invades the privacy of his entire family
on a minute-by-minute basis and often uh
grow testably mischaracterizes the truth
but no matter there's money so he'll
keep quiet about that
but there's a major flaw also in Harry's
campaign against press invasions of the
Privacy is this he's made his own
privacy a ruthless public commodity
trading in his secrets and those of his
family and his friends and sometimes
even the people he lost his virginity to
to the highest bidders the prince who
fled Britain to protect apparently his
family's privacy as laid bare every
tordry detail of his private life and
theirs in this tell-all Memoir from drug
abuse to intimate conversations with his
father the king at his grandfather's
funeral he gave exclusive access to
images of his children to the Netflix
cameras he taught TV studios discussing
his frost bitten todger to sell copies
of his book he charged Royal watches 30
each to watch a live stream of the
therapy session in which she again
boasted about his drug use how much
self-destruction of your own privacy can
a public figure get away with before
they abrogate their right to privacy but
privacy isn't really at the heart of
Harry's Crusade he's made that Crystal
Clear by selling it to the highest
bidders now what Harry really wants is
control he can control the narrative in
Netflix shows he can control the
questions he's asked in publicity jump
kits he can't control his version of the
truth in his book
all books what he cannot control is a
free press and yeah a free press warts
and all good bad and ugly are the type
we have in this country is the very
Cornerstone of a democracy and that's
why Harry who wants complete control
over everything that said and written
about him is so afraid of our Free Press
well joining me now as a broadcaster
Jessica Goddard and professor of
politics and author Matt Goodwin okay
Tricia you're the case for the defense
off you go
um and why am I wrong about this point I
don't want to get into my new side of
the individual cases one of them
involves the mirror group and when I'm
sure he'll have a good old whack at me
while he's doing it I don't want to get
into that because we can't for the legal
reasons however on the general point I'm
making which is yeah of course as a
member of the royal family he's had his
private life raked over the goals for
decades of course they all have and in
return
the others all accept that the deal is
that you get the Palaces the servants
the fancy life you're the biggest stars
in the world and the oppressor like an
annoying Buzzard on the backside of a
bison
um Harry sees it in a much more
malevolent way but then of course comes
the hypocrisy of the book The Netflix
series everything else where he seems to
just be relentlessly invading his own
privacy that of his family that of his
friends a lot of people he's met on his
on his life how can you have your cake
your privacy cake and eat it well I'm in
a difficult position because I I could
say to a much lesser degree and I'm
nothing like Harry as far as profile is
concerned but I would be the same
because for instance when I was in
hospital in 2008 I think you know one of
the reasons I moved to the States was I
didn't have any privacy there I didn't
have privacy when I was in hospital I
had journalists trying to pretend to
deliver flowers my kids had to go
through security and what have you now
I'd written a book about my life and I
talked about my life in minutia and yet
there was a line I didn't think it was
fair to cross now we all have our own
lines and our own boundaries and they
met might not make sense to other people
but I think as you're right you're right
in that if we feel we're controlling the
narrative if I wanted to talk about my
Hospital experience which I did to a
certain amount of dream that's fine if
somebody wants to be under hand and
pretend to be delivering flowers and get
surreptitious pictures of me when I'm
going through chemotherapy that is
something else so I think this whole
court case it I think is the difference
between queen Harry having and you're
right their control
an underhand alleged underhand methods
of people getting another narrow
narrative I think we all have a public
face we all have a private Faith okay uh
Matthew Goodwin your response to this
does Harry have any right to privacy now
can he go and have court battles over
his private life given what he's now
done to his private lives well I think
as a couple they've made a conscious
decision to put themselves out there and
I think there's something else that
Harry can't control which is what do
people think about him and if you look
at the polls on Harry and Megan and I
spent a lot of my time looking at the
polls well I've never seen a brand
collapse this hard this quickly since
the end of last year both Harry and
Megan are down 40 points we've just had
a poll In America which shows he's less
popular now than prince Andrew in
America so as a brand and Danny totally
I've been bouncing this latest thing off
people and they're like get me straight
he's going all the way from La for a a
part of the process he doesn't need to
be at just to be in the papers going
through the front entrance and he's
laughing yeah what kind of thing is is
he thinking he's representing here what
image is he putting forward I think they
think they're The Underdogs going up
against the city the public won't see
that but the cost of living crisis we
haven't had in 100 years I think there's
any going to be any sympathy honestly I
don't thought
is he looking for sympathy I mean he's
not the only one who's made of Avengers
but well he's not the only one who's
very visible in this and as you
mentioned there are other people David
furnished
Doreen Lawrence if Doreen Lawrence is
pretty much saying exactly the same
thing as Harry and I'm sorry with Doreen
Lawrence that infuriates me now
everybody is saying the same thing well
on dore-in-laws we are pretty much we
have to be clear that the male have
issued a robust they absolutely denial
of all these allegations and in
particular about Doreen I agree and
there is a messy situation involving
some of the West muscle blowers now
recounting what they set so let's wait
and see how this is what I'm saying is
what the people that they're saying what
they're claiming is fairly similar but
you know David finished all the rest of
them
um so I think it is it is about control
and when you say about him laughing as
he goes into court I don't know why but
it brings to mind somebody else's been
laughing in Rwanda I mean some yeah
inappropriate sometimes people do stupid
things in serious situations there's
also a sadness here isn't it Matthew and
he's a sadness because he's over here
and he's flown all this way to go and
have his little moment in in the in the
court and in the papers because he hates
the Press but he's not being seen by any
of his family it's been reported his
father doesn't want to see him his
brother doesn't want to see I don't know
that well it's been reported by the
telegraph he's pretty plugged into the
Royals the King has no room in his
schedule right if my son flew 5 000
miles uh to the city I was in I'd be
seeing my sons any of them right so this
is clearly a massive Rift here
apparently he and Megan haven't even
said if they'll go to the coronation I
don't know why who they think they are
to be keeping the king waiting on
whether they come or not but it just
seems again the priorities are
completely warped here yeah I feel sorry
for Harry actually I think he's a deeply
Disturbed
um young man who needs a lot of support
and I think if you look at the therapy
session that he did in the U.S that is
not something that I think somebody who
is completely in command of their you
know of of themselves and is getting
good advice from public relations people
has a supportive team around them I
don't think that's something that that a
person like that would do so when I look
at him I see someone actually who's
quite lost yeah I agree with you you're
an expert in people right
I tell you you've always been you've
always been great at giving people
advice no I agree I actually agree with
Matthew I think the people around him
have given him crap advice yeah whatever
I agree really do and and also because
there's a disconnect the people around
him a lot of them are Americans well
let's be closely clear about when you
say that look I think the main driver of
a lot of this is Megan as well
she's an American who's probably got
exactly what she wants out of there
she's back in living in the state she
grew up in a massive mansion with
hundreds of millions
about the royal family I don't I don't
know
but I don't know whether that is or not
but I'm coming back to Matthew's point
the people around him we all come up
with stupid ideas from now and again if
you're in the media and somebody says oh
come on shut up there is nobody around
he's got a lot of enablers and they're
fueling his kind of Perpetual victimhood
And yet when I watched him marching into
court the last couple of days I don't
see a victim at all I see a very I see a
victim do you I see a victim of
circumstance of uh to Echo youth of
tragedy of pain of of not wearing
knowing where they are of being lost and
there's many people in Memphis how much
can you milk yeah I see when you you're
actually born into gigantic privilege
and when so many millions of people are
going through genuine life or death
hardship right now I just think there is
a very limited pool of sympathy for
Prince Harry right now in this country
for watching him take on the media again
and railing about privacy people like
hang on hasn't he just done a book about
all his private life yeah I see a symbol
of everything that's wrong with our
culture and to be honest everything
that's wrong with well you've written a
good book about it values voice and
virtue which touches on a lot of this
right yeah so basically it's about how
we got here as a country how have we
gone through the last 10 years of
political turbulence and my argument in
a nutshell is we now have a new Elite in
this country that has become dangerously
disconnected from the values that are
held by most people out there who feel
that they don't have a voice in the
conversation and they're looking at this
Elite embracing this radical woke
ideology and they're saying well what on
Earth is this and why do you keep
undermining the things I love like the
institution well I completely agree
you're shaking your head but I think
instinctively you know bit of truth to
this this woke stuff's not completely
out of here I hate the misuse we're
journalists though let's not misuse the
word woke for what it was let's call it
I don't know what you want to call it
but young people I think there is not
just young people I think there's a
disconnect between the I agree there's a
disconnect
um I think I'm generalizing here between
youth between Generations which isn't
very different from the days of Bill
Haley and the Rockers and what have you
but there is a you know woe to me is a
word that people use when they it's like
a catch-all and it's all nearly always
misused I would say there's a disconnect
between the when you call them the lead
I'd say the the politicians it's not
just the politicians anymore though no
at the moment for the last 10 years
we've had the same political people in
power so if you're gonna moan about
immigration and everything else we're
you know for sure for sure on the left
on the right but it's also the greatest
cultural institutions I also think
though we've become as a society
pathetically weak and we now celebrate
victimhood and we celebrate weakness
over strength and winning and ambition
and aspiration and it's making us a weak
Society I really do believe that I don't
think I think we are honestly I don't
think I think there's I think Harry in a
way personifies he's always privilege
all this money he went for Freedom he
doesn't seem happy other than what he's
taking on the media and it's like really
just get over yourself mate get on with
your happy life in California stay with
your chickens drop drop the Royal titles
because why would you want titles given
to you by an institution you hate so
much right drop it all and then you give
your kids the time so I mean come on the
whole thing is riddle with hypocrisy
anyway thank you happy to see you
Matthew you're coming back a little bit
later thank you very much we're coming
next tonight six people including three
children ages nine are killed in another
school shooting in America
how is this still happening what can
happen to stop it anything
or debate the after break
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to pierce organized it's
another 87th day of 2023 but America's
experience is 129th mass shooting of the
year three children aged just nine and
three adults were killed at a school in
Nashville Tennessee a former student
Audrey Hale a biological woman
identifies as a transgender or did
before she was killed and apparently
used his male pronouns but frankly who
cares about the pronouns we've seen on
the school CCTV armed with two assault
weapons and a handgun shooting at the
school's front doors and then prowling
around the school corridors before
killing six people footage from police
body cameras has been released showing
the moment they approach and kill the
shooter in a warning some viewers might
find this distressing
pushing lpbs go right
[Music]
move move
watch out
stop moving stop moving
what's left what's left suspect down
suspect down
we'll certainly my comparison to the
appalling coward is shown by police at
the avaldi mass shooting but you may
remember uh 20 uh were killed the police
there deserve full uh credit for the
courage that they showed in taking down
that shoot joining me now is Ashby
Beasley who herself survived a mass
shooting in Illinois only last year
along with Fox news commentator and Alki
Coast Tommy lahren who lives just
minutes away from the school the scene
of this latest shooting well welcome to
both of you
um I want to start with you Ashby if I
may now you and your six-year-old son
were present at a shooting in Highland
Park Illinois last summer where seven
people were killed and 48 injured and
then by an extraordinary coincidence
having campaigns since then for gun law
reforms you happen to be on a family
vacation right in Nashville when this
latest shooting happened and you went
down to the scene and you spoke
incredibly movingly to the media that
were there let's take a look at this
aren't you guys tired of covering this
aren't you guys tired of being here and
having to cover all of these mass
shootings I'm from Highland Park
Illinois my son and I survived a mass
shooting over the summer I am in
Tennessee on a family vacation with my
son visiting my sister-in-law I have
been lobbying in DC since we survived a
mass shooting in July I have met with
over 130 lawmakers how is this still
happening how are our children still
dying and why are we failing them
well they're good questions uh Ashby
thank you very much indeed for joining
me what motivated you to go there and
and say such a passionate thing there to
the media
you know only in America can someone
like me who survived a mass shooting
last year with my six-year-old son go to
a rally in DC that is being put on by
the survivors of another mass shooting
Newtown Connecticut
and then stopped by to visit my
sister-in-law in Nashville and meet up
with a friend whose son was killed in a
mass shooting in a Waffle House in
Antioch Tennessee who I met in DC
lobbying and only on the day when we
plan to have lunch could another mass
shooting happen down the street from
that friend's you know Sun School a son
who was at the mass shooting that killed
his brother only in America can you find
yourself in that kind of a situation I
mean just Harry you know when she called
well just sorry just to drop it just to
hear what you've just said I've got to
say sitting here in London that kind of
sentence is just extraordinary to people
here it's not to me because I've lived
and worked in America for a long time
but it's just the relentlessness of
these shootings and in particular the
relentlessness of school shootings there
have been I think over 80 school
shootings in America this year alone I
mean we had a appalling one in the UK in
dunblane Scotland in 1996 and we
irrevocably changed a lot of our gun
laws and we didn't have the same amount
of guns in circulation just to be clear
there's a different problem here
um this was the front page of the Daily
Mirror at the time I was the editor I
helped drive a campaign to make things
safer and we've not had a school
shooting since 1996. America's had over
80 this year what do you think Ashby is
the answer to this because Congress
which would change the rules change the
laws seems completely locked on this
completely gridlocked almost like
nothing can be done
well I'm glad that you said 1996 because
since 1999 children in American schools
have experienced gun violence over 350
000 children have experienced gun
violence in schools since 1999. so you
change your laws in 96 we haven't
changed our laws since then and the toll
is just growing our government needs to
step in our lawmakers need to step in
and they need to pass gun safety
legislation the access to weapons of war
that acts the easy access to guns is
what's killing us it's what's killing
our children and there is no other
answer than passing gun safety
legislation ninety percent of American
citizens support background checks
Universal background checks let's do it
let's get it done right let's bring in
Tommy here look Tommy you and I have
discussed guns I mean it seems like
forever this is a groundhog day debate
I'm not going to sit here as a Brit
until Americans how to lead their lives
I tried that once it didn't go down very
well so let's try a different tactic
here which is I think the key phrase
which I heard there from Ashby was
rather than using gun control which is
complete anathema to many Americans
particularly in a British accent because
you as you rightly point out drove us
out with guns so you don't want to hear
it from us I get it I get all that
but she mentioned gun safety
what can be done to make things safer
because things far from getting safer in
America all what's happening is the
number of guns in circulation are
exponentially increasing well over 400
million now and so the number of
shootings are increasing mass shooting
school shootings everything's increasing
you as an American citizen cannot be
happy about that surely what do we do
about it
well I will tell you this I want to talk
about the mental health aspect of this
in a moment but first I want to address
the gun rights and the gun safety debate
in question so here in the United States
we use guns to protect everything that
we hold near and dear to protect our
politicians our celebrities our red
carpets our jewelry stores you name it
everything that we deem important we put
people with firearms that are trained to
use those Firearms to protect those
entities and those individuals we do not
protect our schools like we should and
if you look into this Shooter's
background you look into their Manifesto
they had a map of this school because
what we use to protect our schools is a
little sign that says gun-free zone so
when you're looking at soft targets if
you are a psychopath a freak a monster
you look for places where you can go and
cause Carnage and damage where nobody
will be able to stop you now thank God
for our Nashville officers that
responded so quickly and were able to
neutralize that monster and that threat
but had we had somebody outside of that
school that was trained with a firearm
they could have neutralized that well
hang on yeah
we know what happened at uvaldo there
were hundreds of good guys with guns and
none of them had the guts to go into
anything about it and 20 kids got killed
so it's not a given that actually if you
have a load of people who are good
people with guns in these schools it
makes any difference we saw what
happened on the video here about what
this person did but on a wider point I I
tweeted today for example look rather
than get into the same old debates what
about uh regulating guns in America as
in the same way you regulate cars and I
got an unbelievable amount of abuse
immediately just endless abuse as if I
didn't know what I was talking about but
when I actually then posted a piece by
Nick Kristoff who was at the New York
Times at the time and I explained what I
meant and I'm just going to praise you
what what the piece was a brilliant
piece it was a few years ago but he said
if we had the same also fatality rate
today that we had in 1921 by my
calculations we'd have we'd have 715 000
Americans dying annually in vehicle
accidents instead we've reduced that
fatality rate by 95 percent not by
confiscating cars or taking them away
but by regulating them and their drivers
more sensibly and then he goes into all
the things that have happened in that
period right they talked about requiring
driver licenses uh putting speed limits
registering Vehicles all of that was
originally met with ridicule when
authorities in New York City saw in 1899
to ban Horseless carriages in the Parks
the idea was lambasted as devoid of
Merit and impossible to maintain by the
New York Times yeah over time as more
and more people were being killed by
cars they brought in more and more
regulation by the 1920s a lot of this
stuff like car registration license
requirements other safety measures and
then over time seat belts airbags padded
dashboards better bumpers rules about
drunken drivers graduated licensing the
young people improved Road engineering
blah blah blah
the upshot of all that was that there's
now just over one car fatality per 100
million miles driven and so it was a
very well argued point and at the center
of it was not a claim which I know goes
down very badly with gun owners in
America that you want to ban guns or
grab guns I'm always going to gun
Grabber I don't want your guns trust me
um but about making it as safe as cars
doing what happened to cars why not just
do that and see what happens
well here's the thing somebody that's
going to go into a school and murder
children is not like your average driver
who needs to obey a speed limit or wear
a seat belt somebody that's going to go
in to murder students clearly does not
care about laws in general so what does
making law-abiding citizens making it
harder for us to have firearms what does
that do to stop a monster a psychopath a
freak now I understand your argument
here so we need gun safety we need
people to be trained how to use Firearms
to respect firearms and change the gun
culture in this country I'll also say in
the last 30 years gun ownership in the
United States really has not changed
much what has our mental health
situation and now thanks to the radical
lgbtq movement in this country we are
exploiting mental illness especially in
young people so when you look at this
particular shooter you look at their
background you look at the mental health
counseling and services they were
receiving probably gender affirmation
because that's the new that's the new
status quo now instead of saying this
person has a real mental illness that
needs to be addressed in an individual
basis we clean out Cloud everything
under the guise of gender affirmation
and tolerance the mental health aspect
is very important okay we got a lot of
discussion about gun safety okay to
address mental health and that's being
glossed off I couldn't agree more with
you about mental health all I would
point out is we have exactly the same
mental health problems in this country
and in many European countries and
because we don't have the availability
of guns we don't have 80 000 people a
year dying from Guns uh we had I think
one last year so that's what I would say
in return to that I want to come back to
to Ashby funding for this
the the local Congressman answer
something that she said yes sure can I
ask her something that she said
um you know statistically we know that
mass Shooters 77 of mass Shooters get
their guns legally that means that they
don't have a criminal record that means
that they're not doing the things wrong
they're not on some sort of list
get their guns legally yeah I was going
to make the point that this particular
shooter was a woman transgender I just
I'm not interested in that aspect of the
story other than to say that she
acquired seven guns legally from five
different stalls right to which my and
apparently was at the same time
receiving medical treatment from a
doctor for being emotionally disturbed
now to anyone with half a brain this
seems like an utterly lethal cocktail
but nothing in the system stopped her I
I'm interested also Ashby in in this
this is Congressman Andy ogles who is
the congressman responsible for that
District so he's a U.S lawmaker and in
Christmas 2021 he tweeted this Christmas
card to the World on his Twitter account
let's take a look at this that's him
with his family all clutching guns
including young children Merry Christmas
from the Ogle's family he wrote the
atmosphere of firearms anywhere and
everywhere restrains evil interference
they deserve a place of honor with all
that's good
uh as some people have pointed out
that doesn't seem a particularly
responsible or appropriate thing for a
U.S congressman to be doing and now we
see perhaps in a disturbed mind what
that kind of mindset can do
yes and and if if I'm being honest you
know I look at a picture like that and
the glorifications of weapon the
glorification of weapons of war because
the AR-15 was designed for combat in the
1950s it is a gun that shoots smooth
it's it's an easy shot I shot one
recently
um you can put your your eye on the
barrel when you're firing an AR-15 and
you will not lose your eye it is
designed for ease for killing when I see
a gun like that in a picture like that
what I think of is I think of Mexican
cartels and how at Mexican cartels are
arming themselves with our guns they are
arming themselves with our guns over 200
000 weapons are being trafficked into
Mexico every single year Republicans
like this Republican in this picture is
complaining about the fentanyl crisis on
a daily best basis but all our assault
weapons are enforcing the funds I think
none of our lawmakers are doing anything
yeah I think the truth is they're both
hugely important issues in America they
both have huge toll on life I just think
it's completely inappropriate right
congressman be putting Christmas cards
out with his kids all clutching rifles
like that I'm not sure what message he's
trying to send and I'm not saying he's
responsible glorifying guns yeah
um look Tommy uh and Ashley thank you
very much I mean Tommy you and I we've
discussed this a lot I just hate the
Groundhog Day aspect I love America I
love Americans I respect the Second
Amendment I understand you can't take
all the guns away there are too many of
them this can't go on you can't just
wake up every few weeks and have another
school being shot up by people in
combats with with all these guns
something has to happen something has to
change and the thing I find most
frustrating and dispiriting about it is
Americans are the most can-do people in
the world
they get stuff done and yet on this this
total paralysis and when we did the
campaign in in the UK after dunblane
there was no partisanship or political
difference of opinion it was never
political I never really understood how
it's got that way in America here left
and right came together and when the
lives of kids come above everything and
I think until that is the starting point
I don't think anything happens in
America but look I appreciate we all
have different views on this I also
appreciate I'm not American so I
appreciate you both joining me and thank
you both very much uh well coming next
they're already on 84 000 pounds a year
a lot of money but you're not
politicians actually be paid a lot more
Constantine kissing joins me next to
argue that point
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking good I'm loving it look let's be
honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
we'll be unsurprised to hear that the
disgrace former Health secretary Matt
Hancock has disgraced himself again as
has the disgrace former Chancellor quasi
quite who were both caught up and
undercover sting agreeing to work for a
fake South Korean company for thousands
of pounds a day let's have a look at the
footage from the campaign group led by
donkeys
so we were we were wondering do you have
a daily rate
I do yes it's ten thousand Sterling we
all like to talk about Arrangements of
feeds I mean do you have a daily rate
yeah I mean a yearly rate yes I mean I
would I would say
um as an MP obviously I don't need to uh
create you know earn a king's Ransom but
I'm looking I would do anything less
than for about ten thousand dollars a
month
and so it went unedifyingly on MPS are
allowed to have second jobs there's no
suggestion of parliamentary rule
breaking just pure greed so should MPS
actually be paid more to stop them
behaving in this grasping way in the
first place we're joining me now is the
podcast host and also of an immigrants
love letter to the West Constantine
kissing constantly welcome back to the
program um great to do your podcast by
the way I've had a great reaction to it
good bad and ugly which is the perfect
reaction to anything thanks for coming
on um this when you watched all this and
it's in his full gory details it was so
gruesome to watch and it was the usual
suspect Hancock quieting didn't surprise
me at all the quieting had very little
grasp on reality of money I love the way
I said yearly rate like he's not
upselling you already I did enjoy that
what I mean your takeaway from that was
that you have a belief that MP should be
paid a lot more money I'll just say I
sort of share that view I sort of think
if you paid peanuts you get monkeys
right and we're paying peanuts and
getting people who just seem to me to be
extremely low caliber
politicians and we need to somehow raise
that bar would money alone do that do
you think well the the headline to pay
them more is what people took away from
what I've been saying about this my
viewers yes you pay them more but you
then also ban them from you say they're
allowed to have second jobs they're
allowed to have third jobs and fourth
jobs and first jobs so as long as the
incentive structure is there they're not
getting paid a huge amount for the job
that they're doing obviously compared to
the ordinary person they're they're
being paid to Fair chunk of money but
compared to other people operating at
the top of society I mean if you wanted
your favorite football club to be run by
someone who's very good you'd happily
pay them three four million a year right
in Singapore they pay apparently their
their politicians a lot of money yeah
millions of dollars so they take your
view that you then attract the best
talent your country benefits it's
actually a small price to pay you get
what you pay for and I think with them
you have to ban the second third and
fourth jobs and so on and you have to
make sure that they put the uh stocks
and shares in the trust where they don't
get uh benefits from companies being
trained in a certain way and whatever
but the bottom line is pissed you get
what you pay for and it's interesting I
mean you don't have to get better people
into Parliament right so Singapore they
get 672
000 pounds a year for an average Member
of Parliament Singapore Spain is only 49
000. Germany 108 000 United States
senators 142 000 pounds and France just
under 80 000 pounds so I guess by
comparison to most of Europe ours get
this you know in the kind of middle
range of that but Singapore dramatically
different and they believe over there
they really does attract a better
caliber and that makes perfect sense to
me I just I just think the pro one of
the biggest problems with our politics
is people think about tribe rather than
results and if you're tribal about this
you go well you know Hancock and
quieting of course but actually cast
your mind back to the black government I
mean it's not like they were all squeaky
clean either we have a system in which
the incentive structure encourages
politicians not to take money from us
and to serve us we have a political
system where they take money from some
in this okay some pretend Korean company
and who are they then serving well
exactly I completely agree I want to
switch another story which I thought
would uh would probably get your
interest the Guardian newspaper owners a
guardian being the most woke newspaper
on planet Earth absolutely Beyond
reproach and they've LED Council culture
they've LED wokery they are purer than
pure whiter than white in all things
ethical and they've had an unfortunate
moment today because the Scott trust
that owns a guardian has had to issue a
public apology because it turns out the
origins of the wealth used to establish
the guardian Came From Slavery a review
found the papers founder John Edward
Taylor had links to slavery through
Partnerships in Cotton manufacturing
obviously the guardian reactions to fall
on its knees beg for mercy announce all
sorts of initiatives to prove they're
not a bunch of of racists and so on and
you'd expect that from the guardian but
a comical irony that the paper that's
driven probably more than any
publication in the world this kind of
woke mentality and been picturing
everybody else about their own
shortcomings gets caught like this this
is a very good example of this whole
thing more generally where most of these
people who claim to be kind and
compassionate they behave in the most
awful ways towards the people that they
disagree with and I think this is where
you know I'm not I don't spend a lot of
time reading the guardian I'm not going
to cancel that it's actually bad for my
mental health so I don't but what I do
think is you know everyone lives in a
glass house to some extent and I think
what I take out of this is we should all
throw stop throwing rocks around because
I I genuinely think that if you dig down
long enough every one of us has some
ancestor who did something wrong and the
less we we focus on things that happen
300 years ago and the more we come
together and try to solve the problems
of today I think the better off I just
hit this self-flagellation of the
historical stuff which current people
had nothing to do with what's the point
you know it's like this thing in San
Francisco we're looking to pay millions
and millions of dollars to every black
person who lives in San Francisco as
some kind of reparations from what
previous generations did hundreds of
years ago I don't understand how that
helps anybody no it doesn't and as you
know I talk about it in the book and the
issue of slavery more broadly I just
think we've got stuck in the past and
the way that's completely unhelpful many
of the conversations we have now in the
west are about looking Inward and going
why are we so bad why are we so wrong in
the case I'm making an immigrant's love
letter to the West is we live in one of
the most open tolerant genuinely
Progressive Societies in the history of
humanity let's appreciate that let's at
least notice that for God's sake when do
we stop celebrating our country right I
feel the same way about America new poll
came out today saying the majority of
Americans the first time I can remember
now no longer think it's the best
country in the world Americans always
used to do that right now they don't
there's a kind of again
self-flagellation about the state of the
countries now whereas America and
Britain in many ways are two of the
great countries of the world today
unquestionably and uh to me it's
mind-boggling that we're in this
position but beyond being sort of
frustrated and got all these pink-haired
idiots are running around ruin whatever
to me this is a real threat peas because
if we in the west do not have the
strength of our convictions we do not
have the courage to stand up and say
you know our history is the same as the
history of every other Society we've
done good and bad but on balance we're
good we're good people we are people who
are doing good in the world
um then then other people will come and
take over you know the best works the
best people ever
in the history of this planet have all
been floor Geniuses right I'm talking to
one and you're facing one
two prime examples constantly great to
see immigrants love that as the West
really excellent book making the points
you just make good to see you I
appreciate it thank you first we're
coming next to that Donald Trump hits
out of the Rival Ron DeSantis again
Rhonda sanctimonious as he calls him and
campaigners reckon it's time to ban
Sports terms like Bullseye and hot dog
yes our friends from better are on the
March again and we'll discuss it after
the break
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel no what are you uh every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
hello my darlings catch me next on talk
TV at 9pm I know it sure should I know
it's your show but listen when we're
talking about sentences for criminals
video games going violent and is Ryan
Reynolds going to say football it's all
coming up next on the talk so you better
watch
thank you
well joining me now I'll talk to your
contributor Paula Ron Adrian professor
of politics north of Matt Goodwin's back
with me and political journalist Ava
Santino joins me after we went viral our
last debate so good to have you back to
annoy me
um where should we start let's start
with digital blackface this is the
weirdest thing CNN writer John Blake has
written a whole piece in which she talks
about a term called uh digital blackface
I'm going to wipe people using black
people in memes or gifts to express
comment relief or other emotions is
completely outrageous disgusting sexist
and so on uh examples the crying Michael
Jordan the Tyra Banks how dare you the
Will Smith crying Meme and so on right
um this is complete nonsense isn't it
why doesn't the same apply to white
people gifts and memes of which they are
a gazillion well that's of all you
described it as being weird and secondly
your presentation in regards to
introducing this topic is as if you
don't care I don't and you should care
why and that's exactly why why is a
picture of Michael Jordan this article
was written because we need all to
understand what's happening here and
what's happening is is that there's this
Insidious toxic poisonous racism that
just underlies what's my sister about
Michael Jordan crying he's the greatest
athlete lies this very issue and why
it's important for us why is it
poisonous to have a picture of Michael
Jordan crying as a meme so it's not the
you understand because I'm sure you
would have read the article I did I
thought the article was complete
nonsense but what this is actually about
is about how the picture is presented
and the context that it's presented
Matthew I'm sorry I just think it's all
complete nonsense yeah I mean I my
personal view I think we've entered a
culture where everybody's become far too
sensitive on it really Michael Jordan
cares anyone's doing a meme with him it
is but also cries of the size of his
bank balance yeah but everything it's
everybody's feelings everybody's lived
experience before you know objectivity
and you're still waiting to hear why
that's weird or that's a bad well I'm
asking you though why is it okay to use
memes of famous white people
but not black people yeah but that was
the argument the argument that you
should actually use wipe and the point
being that particularly all the time
particularly Boomers who deploy these
memes it's not really something that gen
Z do anymore or even Millennials you
know they are more racist they are there
are more racist age category I'm sorry
and they are typically maybe not as
funny and they deploy or angry and they
deploy these memes the people of my age
not funny any other things it's very
ages we don't mind me saying because you
understand don't you that in terms of no
I don't inter well then let me help you
no I don't know in understanding race
and in understanding racism we learn
it's a journey in terms of Education you
no longer refer to me as the n-word you
no longer refer to me as colored it's
and I never did my generation never did
well I'm struggling with that one peers
and I think some of your viewers might
be as well you can generalize if you
want well I said some so I'm not
generalizing and I'm also talking about
my personal experience and so what this
author how is any of that affected by a
picture of Michael Jordan one of the
world's greatest athletes crying as a
meme which is used in humor when you
oversimplify it yeah you're missing the
point then you actually kind of
willfully miss it what we're saying is
that you know you're a vegan right let's
move on
they've brought out another list of
things we're not allowed to use in our
sporting terms Bullseye worm burner and
golf catch a crab rowing we can't use
any of these terms because it implies
degradation and mistreatment of animals
they call it speciesism
I think this is deep Beyond helpful I
definitely think we should be talking
about because you agree it's not Meats I
think we should be talking wait a minute
this is a huge moment imagine that this
would convince anyone to think more
carefully about it so you think this is
a pathetic virtue signal I didn't say
that I said I can't I think it's deeply
unhelpful but very virtuously how's that
nonsense and sharing memes is is yeah
exact I don't understand I mean my
students share memes all the time I mean
I don't think it's a generation thing
what we've got we're living through a
cultural revolution these are people
that are trying to church you said that
twice I don't know why you're so fearful
of language or people exploring new
knowledge why don't we ask the children
you just agrees yourself how dangerous
it is yeah we ask the Chinese why should
we be worried about language editing
we're discussing this isn't important
that Peter have come out and said look
this is what we're saying people need to
be aware oh you don't defend this
garbage surely even you I'm saying The
Virtue singular in Chief you want to
dismiss it but that doesn't mean yes
it's important to listen no bull in the
world
how dare you I'm offended you know why
they don't speak English they don't
understand they don't watch the darts
right no worm watches golf no crab
watches the rowing and goes how dare you
they're so grabbing
I think we obviously do know that what
they're talking about is that you're
normalizing the killing of animals and
then you know for children growing up
and hearing that language
animals kill each other yeah Matthew
help me here yeah it doesn't mean you
have to breathe
you're a rose of common sense
I think I think we're losing perspective
I think you know Generations in the past
are looking at us and saying what is
going on down there it's crazy I mean I
think we've we've lost all perspectives
we're evolving we're not evolving
generations
and people who don't want to do that
shout and bang their fists and talk
about fear I'm fearless and I think you
should be as well well you seem very
fearful of a bull being upset by the
word Bullseye which seems to me a reign
of terror which is the like in which
we've never seen I want to show you a
picture of the Pope and I want you all
to be honest when you first saw this
like me did you think wow he looks cool
and nearly posted it right I like it and
then it turns out it's a fake right it's
an AI not chat gbd trip the internet
with a photo of the Pope and a white
puffer jacket and sunglasses Pavia it's
quite a funny story Pablo is that Javier
the credit of him he's told BuzzFeed he
was tripping on mushrooms when he came
up with the idea and just thought it
would be funny is that funny I like it
okay you find that funny it's funny but
I don't know and there's a but there is
a big butt don't tell me there's purpose
no but as human beings I'm a Catholic on
a serious note we're human you found
that funny and what we do is we use our
eyes to help us tell the truth quick
question how are we going to tell the
children was it funny though yes okay so
you find it funny mocking my Pope I'm a
Catholic you see how difficult foreign
looks amazing virtue signaling it's a
very selective business is my Pope as
well I'm a Catholic what did you think
of that I think it's really funny but
then I see
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no what are
you every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one two
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about